our next pair of presenters they're
delightful and very talented young
couple and here they are together again
for the first time mr. and mrs. Robert
Wagner
good evening we have the pleasure of
presenting the documentary award this
evening which is a very important award
wouldn't you agree Natalie yes I
certainly would I always agree with
everything you say RJ why don't you say
that the first time the best achievement
in documentary short subjects a hunter
was his rainy-day Petersham oniy
producer kz giorgio Trevor's producer
selling out Talia's Yavor ski producer
this tiny world Charles and Martina
Huguenots van der Linden produces the
tide of traffic Humphrey swing ler
producer and the winner is the winner is
this tiny world Charles and Martina
Huguenots van der Linden
we are accepting the award for Martita
and Charles and I'm sure they're very
thrilled the nominees for best
achievement in feature documentary
productions are eight and super 8 / 10
straw producer
Malcolm X Marvin Worth and Arnold Pearl
producers Manson producer credit and
controversy Marjo Howard Smith and Sarah
kanakam produces the silent revolution
akkad month producer and the winner is
the winner is Marge oh how it's Moroccan
often
hi there are a lot of people think and
they know they all know who they are but
we would like to single out three people
for a free airtime read Underhill our
Associate Producer Larry silk King of
editors and especially max Gillespie our
executive producer who was really well
max was really more an executive friend
he really had faith in us and came
through whenever we really needed it
so Thank You max and also thanks to all
the friends the production told us to
keep this speech good and short